[Music]
new here noon today an alarming increase
in overdose deaths according to metro
police las vegas saw a 30 percent jump
last year alone
and what's even more concerning right
now for authorities fentanyl deaths
surged nearly 200 percent in a single
year here in the valley hector mejia is
live from metro police headquarters
with the department's fight against
illicit drugs hi hector
hey there the local death numbers are
puzzling metro police now launching a
task force reminding people
if you are not prescribed fentanyl do
not take it and this is why authorities
say
fentanyl can be up to a hundred times
stronger than morphine or heroin
last year alone the number of fentanyl
related deaths surged
from 74 to 219 and that's only here
locally
the synthetic opioid is used to treat
severe pain
authorities say many of the people who
are dying believe they're taking a
prescription grade pill but they're
actually swallowing
a street pill or what's called a pressed
pill
much of the illegal contraband is
believed to come from china and making
its way up through the u.s mexico border
to battle this problem the department
announced the creation of the overdose
response team
a collaboration with local and federal
agencies which include the u.s
attorney's office
the dea and homeland security
emergency this situation does not
discriminate
it does not care how old you are it does
not care
where you live we have responded to
teenagers
we have responded to the elderly you can
see from the map
right here all the places in this
community that we have gone
pandemic absolutely had an impact on
that and
that's why you know we're coming
together
if you or someone you know is struggling
with addiction resources are available
don't forget that you can go to
lvmpd.com
after a few easy clicks you'll find the
helpful links tab
there you'll see a booklet called the we
care booklet which has a list of
resources including local hotlines that
are open
24 7. and today authorities also said
that if possible they'll charge drug
dealers with murder
which carries a minimum sentence of 20
years in prison
if convicted reporting outside metro
police headquarters hector mejia
8 news now